Valley flood patterns changing in Las
Vegas that's what a new study shows from
the desert Research Institute Mary Jane
bellies alive now she is at Eastern and
Desert Inn with more on why and what
that means for those of us who live here
Mary Jane
well Brian this wash is just one of the
many flood channels across the valley
and as you can see it stretches hundreds
of miles returning storm water back to
Lake Mead now that study shows the shift
of seasonal flooding and how the city is
adapting
in just the past several years the Las
Vegas population grew to over 2 million
with the growth comes the need for flood
channels and drainages and monitoring
our ever-changing weather patterns guayu
with the desert Research Institute is
studying how Urban Development and the
climate can alter flood risks and how we
can adapt the Clark County Regional
Flood Control District built a number of
storm drains to push water away from our
city and into Lake Mead
before that we can see more flooding
occurring like um
The Innovation across the city but after
the initiation of La control is realized
lies Innovation is happening here in Las
Vegas but but more water occurred in the
downstream the study also looked at how
floods now happen more in the winter
instead of the historically Summer
monsoon season genvarian a meteorologist
with the National Weather Service says
Winters are a wet season we have the
winter rain which is about half of the
rainfall that we typically get in a
season or in a year and then the monsoon
is about the other half to three
quarters so since December 1st which is
the start of meteorological winter we've
had .69 so we have seen more winter
flowers than the summer class in most
recent uh it was three decades so that
is related to the climate change
developing and implementing flood
control Master plans for the county now
individual flood control plans must be
reviewed every five years reporting live
Mary Jane valleza 8 news now Mary Jane
thank you now before the regional flood
District was created the U.S soil
conservation service documented 184
distinct flood events in Clark County
that resulted in Damages to both private
and public property